Julia thank you for joining us on New
York Times reporter the expose has to do
with the Redskins cheerleaders told to
serve as escorts for sponsors on the
unsavory Costa Rica trip fill us in on
all of this information if you can
Juliet yeah the group of Washington
Redskins cheerleaders went to Costa Rica
for their annual calendar trip in 2013
it turned out to be a little more than
they had signed up for which was you
know in these calendar shirts as some
people might know the calendars include
women scantily clad sometimes without
tops on you know they're hiding their
breath but they're pretty risque poses
and the Redskins had invited some
sponsors who are all male to come and
watch these photo shoots in which the
women were sometimes completely topless
or completely naked but just with body
paint so these women felt uncomfortable
at that point but not as uncomfortable
as they felt a few days later when their
team director had called nine of the
women out after a one evening practice
and said sponsors had hand-picked them
to go to a nightclub and uh and party
party with the sponsors one night and
some of the women started crying they
were calling home calling their
boyfriend saying they felt unsafe they
went to the club without their passports
and we're told to hold and drink drink
with the men and on the way out I guess
the police had stopped them because they
thought they were prostitutes so this is
the situation where the risk and
cheerleaders finally decided that they
had crossed the line and they reached
out to us to tell their story so this
was 2013 let it happen yes and when did
you hear from the former cheerleaders
well we just wrote this story was just
ran yesterday so this was this was
recent okay although this was not a
one-off type of trip where the women
were asked to entertain sponsors in that
manner they've been having these
calendar trips every year and sponsors
were formally invited the [ __ ] said
for several years although many years
including recent years these sponsors
have just shown up on their own to hang
out at the resort or to hang out at the
dinner time or try to try to go out with
these women and this is
we have these type of things didn't not
only happen on these trips but also here
in Washington okay so this wasn't a
one-off here this said there was a
pattern here exactly this was this 2013
trip was though was the one trip that
maybe was the most egregious but we've
since have gotten calls from other
Redskins cheerleaders who are telling us
other story so this was definitely not a
one-off but didn't Daniel Snyder take
over or put the cheerleading aspect or
you know this part of their franchise
in-house they did he like take a little
bit more ownership of it when he took
over this team yeah when when Dan Snyder
brought the team in 1999 he brought the
cheerleaders who were the [ __ ] ass a
terrible name but the [ __ ] s he
remained them the Washington Redskins
cheerleaders brought them in-house and
basically made made them more risk game
less family friendly scantily more
essentially clad outfits for on game day
and the calendar shoots got a little
more risque it's like somebody on
Twitter responded to a the story
yesterday saying that he used to work
for the Redskins and he was told when he
was copy-editing the calendars and there
are words and the calendars I'm told
what he was copy-editing them to try to
make things more more risque so so it's
it's when Dan Snyder came in this
organization took it took a different
turn Snyder was not on any of these
junkets know he would not now you put in
the New York Times article that a Snyder
owned radio station once ran a contest
where winners would you'd get a
cheerleader to wash your car and then
ask yeah was that believe it or not yeah
five lucky winners would get the
Redskins cheerleaders didn't they've
come over and wash your car and it was a
I just the two guys there are two guys
and on that in the ad they were talking
back and forth kind of breathy voices
and one said like wouldn't you like the
opportunity for the Redskins
cheerleaders to scrub you come over and
scrub you or something or soap you up
and scrub you so is a you know obviously
sex sells but I you know they were
really putting it out there in a way
that had a good
done before what did the [ __ ] say
when they did you contact Daniel Snyder
or [ __ ] official of course of course
we did yeah we had a response from the
Redskins they not only did they offer
the team director for the cheerleaders
who denied most of what happened in in
Costa Rica although she acknowledged
some other some other things happened on
a boat trip that they had the other year
prior but they basically said that they
had never heard of any complaints and
and this is this was news to them maybe
Commissioner responded to this did you
reach out to him as well we reached out
to the NFL and they gave us say a
believer there's a statement in the
story saying you know we try to work
with our clubs to for every for all the
truthers and all the employees to be
treated fairly but Havana fella said in
the past that not every NFL team has
cheerleaders so it's not really it's not
really something that they deal with
because it's not league wide so it would
be dealt with team by team yeah you have
some other I mean I encourage people to
read this I mean it's sad when you when
you read it but this is you know what we
going on five years ago but there are
other moments here and other incidents
here and the timing of this is well
Juliet because you got the Saints
cheerleaders and the dolphin
cheerleaders who you know have something
in play right now with the league and
have you heard from other cheerleaders
from other teams we have yeah and this
is not like I said before this is not a
one-off situation and you mentioned that
it was five years ago but you know the
one sponsor who was on all these trips
that I mentioned in the story yeah he
ended his sponsorship just last year so
these road trips that they took every
year there was partying on and men
throwing money at the women you know a
lot of lot of drinking and some women
felt uncomfortable they didn't want to
be on these mandatory trips which the
team said born mandatory but uh you know
these things are going on as we speak
you know I can't I don't know of any
situation that went on yesterday but you
know to say that the Reds
or any of these teams have changed their
policies in the last few years that
would be surprising because it's it's a
culture it's a culture of how they
entertain their sponsors Juliette great
stuff thank you we appreciate you
joining us that's Juliette maccer New
York Times reporter for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]